sometimes you can catch important things
about human nature
in apparent incidentals it's well
observed that between the ages of around
1 and 12
many children manifest a deep attachment
to a stuffed soft object normally shaped
into a bear a rabbit or less often a
penguin the depth of the relationship
can be extraordinary the child sleeps
with it talks to it cries in front of it
and tells it things it would never tell
anyone else what's truly remarkable is
that the animal looks after its owner
addressing him in a tone of unusual
maturity and kindness it might in a
crisis urge the child not to worry so
much and to look forward to better times
in the future but naturally the animals
character is entirely made up the animal
is simply something invented or brought
to life by one part of the child in
order to look after the other the
english psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott
was the first person to write seriously
and with sensitivity about the business
of teddy bears in a paper from the early
1960s Winnicott described a boy of six
whose parents had been deeply abusive to
him becoming very connected to a small
animal his grandmother had given him
every night he would have a dialogue
with the animal would hug him close to
his chest and shed a few tears into his
stained and graying soft fur it was his
most precious possession for which he
would have given up everything else as
the boy summarized the situation to
Winnicott no one else can understand me
like bunny can what fascinated Winnicott
here was that it was of course the boy
who had invented the rabbit given him
his identity his voice and his way of
addressing him the boy was speaking to
himself
via the bunny in a voice filled with an
otherwise all too rarely present
compassion and sympathy although it
sounds a little odd speaking to
ourselves is common practice throughout
our lives often when we do so the tone
is harsh and punitive
we upgrade ourselves for being losers
time wasters or perverts
but as Winnicott new mental well-being
depends on having to hand a repertoire
of more gentle forgiving and hopeful
inner voices to keep going there are
moments when one side of the mind needs
to say to the other that the criticism
is enough that it understands that this
could happen to anyone
that one couldn't have known it's this
kind of indispensable benevolent voice
that the child first starts to rehearse
and exercise with the help of a stuffed
animal in adolescence animals tend to
get put away they become embarrassing a
vocal vulnerability we're keen to escape
from but to follow Winnicott if our
development has gone well what was
trialed in the presence of a stuffed
animal should continue all of our lives
because by definition we will frequently
be let down by the people around us who
won't be able to understand us won't
listen to our griefs and won't be kind
to us in the manner we crave and require
every healthy adult should therefore
possess a capacity for self nurture that
is for retreating to a safe secluded
space and speaking in a tone that's
gentle encouraging and infinitely
forgiving that we don't formally label
the understanding self white rabbit or
yellow bear shouldn't obscure the debt
that the nurturing adult self owes to
its earlier embodiment in a furry toy a
good adult life requires us to see the
links between our strengths and our
aggressive childlike States being
properly mature demands a gracious
accommodation with what could seem
embarrassing or humiliatingly vulnerable
we should honor stuffed animals for what
they really are
tools to help us on our first steps in
vital business and knowing how to look
after ourselves
you
you